this is Joshua and Margaret
investigations again we learned so
little about anyone's backstory it's
such a shame no this one we get a lot of
info I'm gonna look very blue now so
pretty much you got when we get the
backstory of Jake's parents and why Jake
can do what he does I actually was just
thinking in one of those episodes Oh Sam
like ya gonna explain that because we're
getting so much past history of the
other characters and then they finally
do you know um so his parents it turns
out we're investigators and even when
she was pregnant she wanted to keep
going and investigate and they came
across a monster who bites Jake's dad
and so she goes to try and get a formula
she thinks will help so she gets the
venom from Lundy's things that good it
does something at the end like you know
transports it to a different dimension
or something in the coolest way that
makes us a good god I want to know what
the hell is going on there it makes me
think of a spirograph yeah I almost
wanted to see that scene again just a
white kept EMA she was so cool there
it's just the way more than any way uh
so eventually it turns out what's
happening takes dad is a he's actually
given birth to Jake and then the mother
gives birth to the brother
and that's why Jake can't turn anything
cuz he's actually the product of one of
those things that can turn it to
anything I think there was only one
that's my guess I think there was just
only actually one well one it just kept
changing another stuff he that's be
really fast but again we saw he could
teleport to different places you know he
actually he's separated into two yeah
that's two so that very well could be
just one lung creature and if it is one
which I think you're right the guy hit
to get because it could break into other
ones uh
I'm even more interested I mean that
just suddenly created like a huge what
the hell I
know the story here yeah behind this
creature and obviously it was part of
its plan cuz as soon as she got the
venom or whatever he starts laughing and
then he goes into the other dimension
there are you a baby and yes we get a
nice backstory there and that I I really
like the couple I like the mom and dad I
like the way to work off each other I
like how they talk like you know a
1940's investigators yes they almost hit
me on the noggin you know I mean it's
like I like all that talk and I like how
quickly they talk um the only thing that
just it's just purely me thing the only
thing I constantly made me nervous is ya
watchin a pregnant woman go we'd do all
that stuff might get stuck in a tree or
when she's like rolling over on their
stomach I was just like I don't know
that stuff just makes it even if it's an
to me it just makes me nervous I can't
outfit yeah I just get really nervous
about that stuff but still funny
uh but your girlfriend what you mean
what tree trunks you forgot the entire
tree trunks crap Vanessa I mean okay she
goes and her pie is stolen by her first
presumably first husband I wonder if one
of the first three yeah and but they
find out it was just the husband but
there was a monster - to be honest I
didn't think there was that much tree
tries to mention and I didn't because I
know you don't like her so I but its
trunks and I thought you were Jay well
this cameo wasn't nearly as funny as
when she turned to that guy's head that
was no see that was a cameo this was not
a cameo
yes it was she was there for only two
minutes out of whatever the ten yeah
that's like one fifth of the episode
that's sick okay a slightly bigger cameo
I didn't think she was a major player in
this but major player okay so what what
do you have to say about tree trunks how
old is this woman she did sound exactly
the same age and she sounded just as
dumb and she was before her she is now
but here's the thing Jake came out and
he was immediately talking and dancing
and stuff so I mean for all we know
maybe he's just like to know cuz Finn
they found him when he was like a baby
yeah okay well maybe he's a mutant human
no that makes no sense I don't know
elephants can live a long time
especially if they make pie well they
can I know elephants lived for a long
time but still it's just like she
sounded as dumb as she was now why don't
I just making her smartest sounds like
she's old and only got older like the
mind is slowly falling apart or maybe
quickly the mind was already falling up
yeah maybe there's no mind there to
begin with yeah no she still makes me
laugh
see I'm friends you to bring her up it's
a the crying husband they just wanted
thirds and fourths I wanted to stop what
I wanted to is it every is when she
talks everything she says sounds like no
thoughts being put into it just as soon
as it comes to her head like it goes to
the mouth and nothing is perceiving how
it's going to sound at all and I I love
that I know you're fired annoying but I
love it
sure what do you call it vocal diarrhea
oral Diaries but no I didn't like the
episode I don't know what you think of
it it was okay once I mean like I guess
and it's stupid to say it was
predictable like once the things started
moving in like islands that were Jake's
coming from you know yeah you thinking
about prettier oh I know you you had a
theory that like Jake was the dad or is
there no where we say Jake came from the
dead okay he realized the dad and that's
where I was like what no no I was kind
of mumbling to myself because I remember
he had Jermaine his brother yeah so it
was one of those things where it's like
okay there has to be a second one and it
just makes sense what this thing's
starting to move that creature being
able to transform like oh that's
probably Jake's father
to somehow be connected but I didn't
think it would actually come from the
father I do like the fact too that Jake
technically doesn't know yes guy from
yeah 301 it's a good ending but it also
leaves it open for when they do reveal
you know he really knows nothing so all
of this can be explained to him and thus
to us and we can have this mystery
trying to find out what that creature is
it's a it's a good choice to not have
him know yet well I love how he's like
Oh tell us the story about how your
heart okay
the story starts and then when it gets
too nice like so they never told me yeah
that's like what he started off yeah I
get that way I love how they tell the
entire story but Jake never actually
tells anything I love that yeah it's
like all that really happens in real
life he's like well let me tell ya they
never told me yeah yeah like that's
really what happened in real time but
then suddenly there's this flashback in
there I do like that I thought that was
a lot of fun yeah and they also go ha
emo yeah it was good I forgot how much I
miss BMO when I saw BMO again I was like
yeah but yeah this is episode like four
in a row where Finn and Jake haven't
been the main focus yeah um it's been
very other character focused I mean it's
I give a little crack cuz we're learning
one of their histories you know so it's
like it's a little more you know it
there's a little bit more leeway there I
think but yeah I mean that that is for
were like yeah I think maybe maybe the
key to play spin voice is just really
going through and to address it sometime
I mean yeah I don't know I don't know
but yeah that is a little weird that
they've been out of so many um like I
said with this one I felt it it's okay
to have this a collection of them
because it's still the back story Jake
so well I actually really like this
batch I like the I'd liked yeah four in
a row of none Jake Finn and Jake focused
ones but like I really loved again the
wizards I loved peppermint Butler and
this one's a lot of fun too
yeah I mean it got a little slow at a
few times but I mean all know I think a
lot of fun with this this one and this
group that we watched this time yeah and
I didn't feel with this one cuz I know
you're talking about with it being slow
but I think with this couple cuz they
are kind of older and it's more like an
older generation something felt okay
because when it was slow you still felt
them kind of connecting and talking and
working off each other and it still it
it felt almost necessary to have kind of
those slower moments you know and it
didn't feel anything so and yes by the
way that's exactly how a woman sounds
when you know she's about to give birth
oh that's what it looks like to just
like you know actually I will say this
the first time I saw like breeze like
hand or foot kind of like pushing
against jory stomach it's free to
incident hear it as crap like it's just
like you've lost a little kid I heard
like you know you want to feel the baby
kick you got like what it's like
you hear it's like kicking you guess my
valley it's like it's in that awful no
it's cute it sounds awful you see its
face also trying to get there I remember
when Tori was like oh you know it's
kicking because we didn't know the sex
at the time but it's like did you want
to feel it I'm like no I took me a while
before I actually tried to feel and of
course every time I tried to nothing
happened hello my baby yeah exactly
kids got her well trained yes yes I'm
good I'm good too yeah now you guys will
see you next five episodes what do you
want